* Hupen *
* Fliessender Indie-Rock-Song *
# Don't look at me like this,
hun, don't be upset.
# What a wonderful day.
# Don't be mad at me
because I feel alright.
# I can't be happy
if you're not alright.
# Don't worry
cause I really feel alright.
# I go to the USA.
* Fliessender Indie-Rock-Song *
Heute ist der grosse Tag
in Hollywood.
Und der Oscar in der Kategorie
"Bester Chauffeur" geht an:
Randy!
Heute ist die Oscar-Verleihung,
und ich muss meinen Kunden abholen.
Er ist der Präsident
der Disney-Studios.
Zwei ihrer Filme
nehmen am Wettbewerb
in der Kategorie "Animation" teil.
Dieses Jahr bin ich zum 17. Mal
bei der Verleihung dabei.
Ich habe schon
für grosse Schauspieler gearbeitet
wie Bradley Cooper, Ben Kingsley,
Mike Myers und Clint Eastwood.
Leider darf man nicht filmen,
wenn mein Kunde im Wagen sitzt,
auch nicht, wenn wir
beim roten Teppich ankommen,
wegen der Sicherheit.
Deshalb werden Sie diesen Moment
leider nicht sehen können.
Nein,
jetzt filmen geht wirklich nicht!
* Fliessender Indie-Rock-Song *
Die Vernissage der Gruppenausstellung
rückt näher.
"Les Amoureuses", die Liebenden,
ist auf der Zielgeraden.
Das Projekt ist noch nicht ganz
fertig, das ist etwas stressig.
Es gibt viele Collagen,
viele Gemälde.
Viele Entscheidungen
müssen getroffen werden.
Deshalb muss ich hier sein und
mich abschotten, damit alles klappt,
sonst werde ich nicht fertig.
Vor 15 Jahren
habe ich eine Serie gemacht
mit Dekors aus Pasolinis Film
"Die 120 Tage von Sodom".
Ich bin wieder
auf dieses Bild gestossen,
als ich hier
in das neue Atelier eingezogen bin.
Da dachte ich plötzlich,
dass ich etwas damit machen könnte,
dass ich es
"Fluchtraum" nennen könnte
und dass ich es
mit der Idee der Liebenden
oder mit der Gegensätzlichkeit
der Liebenden verbinden könnte.
Ich muss die Idee
noch etwas köcheln lassen,
die richtigen Entscheidungen fällen.
Ich darf
nicht zu viele Fehler machen.
Das bedeutet, dass der
nächste Schritt erst dann kommt,
wenn du sicher bist.
Du musst dir einfach die Zeit geben,
damit du dich konzentrieren kannst
und eintauchst
und abtauchst und untertauchst
und ganz durchtränkt bist!
Hast du die Decke gemacht?
- Ja, alles hängt.
Oh, ich hab es gar nicht gesehen.
Noch ein letzter Abdruck.
Perfekt!
Das geht wieder ab, unglaublich!
Once more.
It's inkless,
it will come right off.
Dein Daumenabdruck
ist viel grösser als meiner.
Das ist der Verkaufspreis.
Ich brauche hier deine Initialen.
Du musst die Papiere unterschreiben,
Schatz.
Wir bleiben bis Ende April.
Wir haben vereinbart,
dass wir das Haus noch einen Monat
bis zu unserem Wegzug mieten können.
Gelesen,
genehmigt und unterschrieben.
Pasqual und Doras Haus
ist nun offiziell verkauft.
Muss ich
alle meine Ex-Frauen angeben?
Nein, nur die aktuelle.
- Nur sie?
Wenn du willst,
kannst du die Rückseite benutzen.
Dann brauch ich
wahrscheinlich zwei Seiten.
Okay.
Ich glaube,
es ist jetzt alles erledigt.
Nun müssen wir nur noch überlegen,
welches Datum wir
für die Rückkehr aussuchen.
Wir müssen natürlich
noch viel packen,
die Finanzen regeln.
Wir müssen schauen,
wie das mit dem Geldüberweisen geht.
Es ist nicht so einfach hier,
leider nicht.
Es ist gar nicht so einfach,
in Kalifornien
seine Steuern loszuwerden.
In der Schweiz dürfe man kein Konto
eröffnen, habe ich gehört,
wenn man von Amerika kommt.
Ich glaube,
es muss über das Postkonto laufen.
Amerika und die Schweiz hatten
Streit wegen ihren Abmachungen.
Sie hatten sich schon geeinigt,
als die Schweizer Banken sagten,
sie wollten gar nichts mehr
damit zu tun haben.
Noch eine letzte Sache.
Wollt ihr einen Scheck oder
eine Gutschrift von Konto zu Konto?
Ich denke, ein Scheck ist besser.
Ich will nicht, dass das Geld hier
auf ein amerikanisches Konto geht
und es dann
1'000 Komplikationen gibt.
Warte, das ist strafbar!
Was ist strafbar?
Du musst das Geld
auf eine Bank überweisen,
die ein Abkommen
mit einer Schweizer Bank hat.
Danke für die Formulare -
alles in Ordnung.
Ist das jetzt alles?
Sind wir fertig?
550'000,
aber 40'000 werden abgezogen.
Dann bleiben uns noch
exakt 510'134 Dollar und 84 Cents.
Ich habe etwas Angst
vor der langen Reise.
Pasqual hat immer
so wahnsinnige Schmerzen.
Wird er sich an die Schweiz
gewöhnen, ans Leben in der Schweiz?
Werde ich mich daran gewöhnen?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Aber wir können immer wieder zurück,
weil wir beide Pässe haben.
Wenn es sein muss, können wir ...
Aber Los Angeles
will ich nicht mehr.
Ich finde diese Stadt nicht schön,
habe sie nie schön gefunden.
Die grössten Studios
haben sich in Burbank angesiedelt,
ganz in der Nähe von Hollywood.
Im Zentrum der Welthauptstadt des
Films gestaltet Roger das Dekor neu.
Das ist der Raum für die Büros.
Two, three, four, five, six, seven
eight, nine, ten - go right to here.
Vorher war ein kleiner Coffeeshop
hier drin.
Er bestand nur aus diesem Raum.
Ich musste ein Konzept für
einen neuen Coffeeshop erstellen.
Das war eigentlich ein kleiner Job.
Ich sagte:
"Ja, mache ich, kein Problem."
Dann haben wir angefangen.
Dann hat sich dieses Projekt
fortlaufend verändert.
Ich besuchte die Sitzungen
und realisierte,
dass alles extrem langsam geht.
Und dann gab das eine das andere:
Kurz bevor ich
in die Schweiz zurückgeflogen bin,
hat er mich angerufen und gesagt:
"Okay, you do everything."
Ich habe nur Angst wegen der Kosten
für die Treppe. Das wird sehr teuer.
Hier muss alles weg,
der Boden, die Wände,
dann wird alles erhöht.
Die Decke höher?
Genau, so hoch wie möglich.
In L.A. ist es einfach so,
dass man irgendwie
eine Chance erhält,
die man nicht hinterfragen darf:
"Soll ich? Kann ich?"
Dann musst du antworten:
"Mache ich!"
Dann arbeitest du
sieben Tage die Woche.
Okay, ich rufe dich nachher zurück.
Okay!
Tschüss! Tschau! Tschüss!
Bye-bye! Tschüss!
I don't want that ...
My mom called.
Kommt vor.
Hier muss man, wie der Kunde
erwähnt hat, einfach flexibel sein.
Du musst den Job annehmen und sagen:
"Jawohl, mache ich."
Es ist eine Chance, deshalb:
Why not?
Hi Reto.
- Hallo. Wie geht es dir?
Gut. Und dir?
Roger leitet das Projekt
für einen befreundeten Investor.
Wie durch Zufall
sprechen sie dieselbe Sprache.
Wenn man ein altes Gebäude,
eine alte Fabrik umbaut,
tauchen viele Sachen auf,
über die man nichts weiss.
Man öffnet eine Wand, eine Decke -
und schon muss man improvisieren.
Drei Grössen, nicht ausgerichtet,
so dass es zufällig aussieht.
Das ist etwas, womit wir in
der Schweiz besser umgehen können.
Wir können improvisieren, nachdem
wir eine Sache begutachtet haben.
Dann können wir die Sache übernehmen
und sagen: "Wir machen das."
Es ist gewaltig, mit einem Schweizer
arbeiten zu können.
Ich sagte ihm: "Wenn du willst,
dass ich den Job übernehme,
musst du meinen Ingenieur,
meinen mechanical guy
und meinen contractor übernehmen."
Nur mit ihnen kriege ich es hin.
Diese Tür muss wirklich
aussergewöhnlich werden.
Wenn du sie öffnest,
dann - wow! -
eröffnet sich dieser Ausblick.
Du musst zackzack vorwärtsmachen,
dafür braucht es
ein gewisses Vertrauen.
Weil wir uns
schon seit 20 Jahren kennen,
ist das bereits vorhanden.
Und dann stammen wir auch noch
fast aus derselben Gegend,
aus der Ostschweiz.
So it is like family almost,
you know.
It's just different.
* Pulsierende Musik *
Der dichte Stadtverkehr
wird Lauriane bald verschlucken.
Ich bin auf dem Weg zu meiner
ersten Fahrstunde in den Staaten,
das erste Mal mit Automatik.
Handschaltung kenne ich
von Fahrstunden in der Schweiz.
Ich weiss nicht, ob das gut geht.
* Drollige Musik *
Ich weiss nicht mehr,
wo wir uns verabredet haben.
Hallo.
Wo sind Sie?
In welchem Parking?
Ah, ja.
Sunset Village Parking, richtig?
Oh, hey!
Ich habe keinen Fahrausweis,
aber ich bin schon 10-20 Std.
mit Handschaltung gefahren.
Okay, dann kennst du
die Strassenverkehrsregeln?
Ja, ich habe
keinen einzigen Fehler gemacht.
Dann lerne weiter.
Das ist wichtig, wenn du fährst,
nicht nur für die Prüfung.
Okay.
Der Blinker.
Das ist, um links abzubiegen, oder?
Und das für rechts?
Nein, mit derselben Hand.
Und jetzt der Rückspiegel.
Ich hoffe, die Schranke geht auf.
Hier ist niemand und da auch nicht.
Es ist so viel besser mit Automatik.
Und du fährst.
- Yeah.
Kann ich abbiegen?
Du muss zuerst anhalten.
- Oh, Entschuldigung!
Nichts zeigt an, dass wir hier
nicht rechts abbiegen dürften.
Da sind Kinder.
Kann ich jetzt fahren?
- Ist es frei? Da sind Fussgänger.
Als wir vom Parkplatz losfahren
wollten, war ich total gestresst.
Ich dachte: "Oh, la, la!"
Ich fuhr seit sechs Monaten,
seit einem Jahr nicht mehr,
aber jetzt geht's ganz gut.
Und der Fahrlehrer ist neben mir,
ich trau mir das zu.
Kein Gegenverkehr,
keine Fussgänger, wir können fahren.
Haben die wegen mir gehupt?
- Schon möglich.
Es gibt nicht viele Kreuzungen
in der Schweiz.
In die Mitte fahren,
um links abzubiegen,
das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Soll ich stoppen?
- Ja.
Sie braucht noch viel Übung,
bis sie sich richtig wohlfühlt.
Sie muss noch
die Verkehrsregeln lernen.
Neulenker lernen oft
das Handbuch nur für die Prüfung
und danach werfen sie es weg.
Wechsle ich jetzt, oder später?
Setz den Blinker jetzt schon!
Los Angeles ist ein Schmelztiegel
aus verschiedenen Fahrstilen.
Es kommen viele Leute her
und fahren dann
mit den Ausweisen aus ihrer Heimat.
Sie studieren nicht mal
die kalifornischen Verkehrsregeln.
Behalt das Tempo bei!
Schau da! Ist da jemand?
Just glide over.
Wenn du hier fahren lernst,
kannst du überall fahren.
Du bist zu weit weg.
Das ist der maximal
zulässige Abstand.
Fahr etwas zurück!
Ist es schlecht,
wenn ich das Trottoir touchiere?
Das Trottoir wird nicht berührt.
Perfekt! Gut gemacht!
Ich hätte gern einen Fahrausweis,
sehe mich aber nicht so recht
mit einem eigenen Auto.
Ich werde wohl
immer etwas Angst haben.
Ich möchte einfach nur den Ausweis,
um einen zu haben.
Ich sehe mich
eher unterwegs mit Freunden,
die einen Wagen haben und fahren,
und ich bin auf dem Beifahrersitz.
* Entspannte Musik *
Hinter den Kulissen
erhaschen Hunderte Chauffeure
einen Hauch von Hollywoods Glamour.
Ich habe gerade meinen Kunden
auf dem roten Teppich abgesetzt.
Jetzt warten wir, bis die Feier
vorbei ist und mein Kunde anruft,
damit ich ihn abholen kann.
Dann treffe ich mich
mit meinen Kollegen,
und wir gehen zusammen an den Ort,
wo Essen und Getränke
für uns vorbereitet sind.
Da gibt es auch Riesenbildschirme,
auf denen man
die Feier live verfolgen kann.
Wir werden
bis ca. 23 Uhr hierbleiben,
und dann geht es zu den Feiern,
die in der Stadt organisiert sind.
Dieses Jahr habe ich
für "A Star is born" gearbeitet,
mit Bradley Cooper und Lady Gaga,
und für "Bohemian Rapsody",
der Film über das Leben
von Freddy Mercury von Queen.
Es gefällt mir, die Verleihung
zu sehen, und später meinen Kunden,
die gewonnen haben,
gratulieren zu können.
Bevor ich als Bodyguard
gearbeitet habe,
war ich zehn Jahre lang beim Film.
Es macht mir Spass,
die Preisverleihungen zu sehen,
nicht alle, aber die Oscars immer,
weil es der wichtigste Abend
in Hollywood ist.
Als ich Schauspieler war,
habe ich immer davon geträumt,
einmal einen Oscar zu bekommen.
Manchmal denke ich,
dass ich als Schweizer Schauspieler
einen Oscar hätte gewinnen können,
für eine grosse Rolle,
die ich hätte spielen können.
Es bleibt ein Traum,
so ist das eben.
* Westerngitarrenklänge *
Es ist ein wenig stressig,
aber mit der Ausstellung
bin ich sehr zufrieden.
Heute Abend wird gefeiert.
Da bin ich dann lockerer.
Das wird lustig. Es ist gut.
Die Arbeit liegt jetzt
in den Händen der Galeristin.
Los Angeles ist zum neuen El Dorado
zeitgenössischer Kunst geworden.
Freiheit und ein volles Portemonnaie:
zwei Konzepte, die harmonieren.
"Les Amoureuses"
reiten auf dieser Welle.
Ich finde es stark,
dass Frauen einen Raum bekommen,
um ihre Arbeiten zu zeigen.
Das ist typisch L.A.,
dass du zufällig
an eine Vernissage gehen kannst.
Das ist sehr schön und positiv.
* Entspannte Klavierklänge *
Dieses Projekt
hört nicht in dem Moment auf,
in dem die Werke ausgestellt werden.
Das ist der Beginn des Abenteuers.
Der grosse Unterschied
zwischen Europa und L.A.
Das ist interessant.
Aber wir sind jetzt
mehr verbunden als bisher.
Und wir sind glücklich,
dabei zu sein.
Ein Raum für Frauen.
Als Künstlerinnen und Mütter
haben die vier Freundinnen
den Grundstein gelegt.
Simon, wir pflücken Orangen.
Let's go.
Die Orangenernte ist bald vorbei.
Die kann warten.
Die Apfelernte steht bald bevor.
Das ist ein Birchermüesli,
das ich mit Kefir anrichte.
Die Früchte habe ich
mit Orangensaft übergossen,
damit sie frisch bleiben.
Sie müssen
separat zubereitet werden.
Meine Schwester sagte mir,
das sei nicht gut.
Früchte würden nicht
so viele Vitamine zurückhalten,
wenn man sie einfach so hinzufügt.
Und meine Schwester
weiss es immer besser.
Zurück in der Schweiz
wird Dora vom Wissen ihrer Schwester
profitieren können.
Sie werden alle zusammen
in ihrem Haus in Meggen wohnen,
in der Nähe von Luzern.
Hallo, Vreni, wie geht's?
Gut, wir haben wunderschönes Wetter.
Jetzt habt ihr schönes Wetter?
Gestern hast du gesagt, es schneie.
Es hat geschneit, aber jetzt
ist die Sonne wieder gekommen.
Kannst du es mir zeigen?
- Ja, ich zeig es dir.
Hier, schau selbst!
Schön,
mit den Bergen im Hintergrund.
Es ist jetzt offiziell,
dass das Haus verkauft wurde.
Gut.
Ich denke, wir werden
vieles gemeinsam machen.
Wir werden zum Teil
auch vieles gemeinsam erleben.
Das finde ich gut.
- Ja, ja.
Wir können uns
gegenseitig unterstützen.
Ja, es muss nur einmal
und nicht zweimal gekocht werden.
Gemeinsam kochen, das ist logisch.
Pasqual sollte sich
nicht zur Seite gestellt fühlen,
wenn wir miteinander
schweizerdeutsch sprechen.
Nein, nein. Das wird gut gehen.
Wenn er verstehen will,
was wir erzählen.
Dann soll er in die Migros Klub-
schule gehen, um Deutsch zu lernen.
Du, ich rufe dich morgen wieder an.
Tschüss.
- Tschau, tschau.
Meine Schwester
ist acht Jahre älter als ich.
Sie war immer
meine grosse Schwester.
Ich bewunderte sie immer.
Ich habe in meinem Leben
einen anderen Weg gewählt.
Sie heiratete und hatte Kinder.
Meine Beziehungen
sind eigentlich immer
hinter meiner Karriere gestanden.
Mir ist nicht in den Sinn gekommen,
Kinder zu haben.
Ich spiele richtig, du nicht!
- Ich spiele allein.
Have fun!
- See you later.
In L.A. muss man
den Swing im Blut haben.
Beim Golfen
wie im alltäglichen Leben
braucht man Energie und muss
seine Ziele punktgenau anpeilen.
In der Stadt des Films und
auf dem Green muss man sich beweisen
und immer wieder von vorn beginnen.
Manchmal glückt eine Partie.
Manchmal verliert man alles.
Oder man bettelt um Koks
und eine schnelle Nummer.
Look out! I feel the presence.
1992 wurde meine Mannschaft
für eine Kinoproduktion engagiert,
für einen Film, für den sie
American-Football-Spieler
für bestimmte Szenen suchten.
Sie wollten Leute,
die Berufsspieler darstellten.
Daher kommt
meine Leidenschaft fürs Kino.
Ich habe mir vorgestellt,
später Schauspieler
oder Stuntman zu werden.
Dann habe ich Schritt für Schritt
meine Filmkarriere aufgebaut,
die zehn Jahre lang gedauert hat.
Das da bin ich
mit Anne Nicole Smith,
einer Schauspielerin
und einem Model.
Ich habe ihren Bodyguard gespielt.
Ich habe auch
viele Musikvideoclips gedreht.
Der da war mit Johnny Gill.
Das bin ich.
Da hatte ich noch Haare,
heute habe ich keine mehr.
Ist auch schon ziemlich lange her.
2001, nach den
Terroranschlägen vom 11. September,
ging plötzlich alles langsamer.
Sie wollten keine Produktionen
lancieren aus Angst vor Anschlägen.
Im Dezember hatte ich dann
finanzielle Schwierigkeiten,
weil ich
nicht so viel gearbeitet hatte.
Ich habe in einigen
grösseren Filmen mitgespielt,
aber ich hatte
nie Dialoge zu sprechen.
Meine Figuren waren meist:
der Bodyguard, der grosse harte Typ.
Aber ich bin schon froh,
dass ich das gemacht habe.
* Entspannte Westerngitarrenklänge *
Im Santa Barbara County
liegt eine wahrhaft schweizerische
Oase des Friedens: Little Walenstadt.
Eine Hommage
an den Kanton St. Gallen,
die Wahlheimat des Architekten.
Es ist so, dass mich diese Gegend
an die Schweiz erinnert,
an die Berge in der Schweiz.
Klar, ist es hier anders, aber ich
ging schon immer gern wandern,
war schon immer gerne
draussen in der Natur.
Das brauche ich einfach. Ich könnte
nicht immer in der Stadt wohnen.
Deshalb wohnen wir auch am Strand
und nicht mitten in der Stadt.
Das kann ich nicht.
Roger und Susanne
haben ihrem Freund Meinrad,
der sich um das Anwesen kümmert,
einen Teil des Grundstücks abgekauft.
Schau, wer da ist!
Mit Früchten aus der Schweiz
von einer Schweizerin gebacken,
es gibt nichts besseres.
Das ist unglaublich.
Willst du daran riechen?
- Ja.
Das fühlt sich
wie verfrühte Weihnachten an.
Herzlichen Dank. Er ist ganz allein
für mich, nicht für euch?
Früher habe ich in der Stadt
gewohnt, in Los Angeles,
einer sehr schönen Stadt.
Da klingelte eines Tages
die Hausglocke.
Als ich die Tür öffnete,
streckte mir jemand
eine Ovomaltine-Dose entgegen.
Ich erkannte keine Gesichter,
nur die Hand mit der Dose.
Ich dachte mir:
"Mein gütiger Himmel. Was ist das?"
Das kann nur jemand aus der Schweiz
sein - und das wart ihr:
"Wir sind nur
für einen kleinen Besuch gekommen."
Dann habe ich Kaffee aufgesetzt -
und Ovomaltine gemacht.
Ich fragte: "Wo wohnt ihr
während eurer Ferien in L.A.?"
"Wir haben noch kein Zimmer."
Ich konnte mir gleich vorstellen,
was das bedeutet.
Mit anderen Worten: "Hast du Platz
in deinem grossen Haus?"
Drei Wochen später
sind sie endlich gegangen.
Das war vor etwa 30 Jahren.
Damals bist du eine Corvette
gefahren, eine nagelneue.
Ja, daran kann ich mich
noch gut erinnern.
Und sie war sehr scheu.
Sie wurde nur schon rot,
wenn ich sie angesprochen habe.
Und später arbeitete sie
als rechte Hand des Generalkonsuls.
Das ist der Wohnwagen,
in dem wir ab und zu schlafen.
Sonst schlafen wir oben im Haus.
Es kommt immer etwas
auf die Stimmung des Wetters an.
Aber ich liebe es,
im Wohnwagen zu schlafen.
Das ist ein totaler Bruch
zum normalen Leben in Los Angeles.
Hier hinten haben wir
Aprikosen- und Apfelbäume,
die jetzt gerade
in der Blüte stehen.
Wir müssen kontrollieren,
ob das Wasserleitungssystem
noch funktioniert.
Dann schneiden wir die Bäume.
Dann sind sie bereit
für die Aprikosensaison.
Neffe Severin profitiert von allem,
was ihm sein Onkel Roger mit
seinem breiten Wissen ermöglicht.
Es hat schon
von klein auf angefangen.
Wenn es hiess, Tante Susanne
und Onkel Roger kämen zu Besuch,
schnellte mein Puls hoch.
Hier ist alles bereit
für die Bienen-Saison.
Siehst du, das sind die Kästen, in
denen die Bienen den Honig sammeln.
In beruflicher Hinsicht
konnten sie mir einige Tipps geben
oder sie versuchten es zumindest.
Einige Tipps
sind sehr wertvoll für mich,
denn Roger hat ja
ein eigenes Unternehmen aufgebaut.
Er hat es von Grund auf
selbst geschaffen.
Das war sicher
nicht ganz einfach in Amerika.
Er hat viel Erfahrung
und kann mir gute Tipps geben,
die sich
als wertvoll erweisen könnten.
Und dann fliesst unten
der Honig raus.
Spannend. Muss man nur drehen?
Ja, man muss
stark und schnell drehen.
Das habe ich
als Rückzugsort gekauft,
um aus Los Angeles
fliehen zu können.
Das ist für mich
ein Ort des Friedens.
Hier oben herrscht die Natur,
es ist still.
Ich arbeite gerne mit den Händen,
tue gern etwas anderes,
als ständig im Büro zu sitzen.
Hier schneide ich Bäume,
mache Honig,
repariere Wasserleitungen,
putze den See usw.
Hier kann ich all die Sachen machen,
die ich sonst nicht so tue.
Das ist gut für die Seele.
Wie soll ich es beschreiben?
Die Natur
lässt sich nicht kontrollieren.
Sie bringt dir bei,
dass du manchmal einfach
mit dem Flow gehen musst,
es unbeschwert angehen musst.
Man darf nichts erzwingen,
trotzdem kommt es irgendwie gut.
Man lernt,
mit der Natur zu arbeiten.
Anfangs habe ich Sachen erzwungen,
aber das hat nicht geklappt.
Dann habe ich
einen Schritt zurück gemacht.
Plötzlich habe ich realisiert:
Wenn ich es easy nehme
und nicht so gestresst bin,
dann fallen die Puzzleteile
plötzlich an den richtigen Ort.
Das ergibt das bessere Endresultat.
Diese Oase inmitten der Wüste
könnte man Little Ticino nennen.
Im Moment ist das gut,
sie ist ja auch allein hier,
ihr Freund ist in Los Angeles.
Wir leisten uns Gesellschaft,
wir unterstützen uns gegenseitig.
Es ist gut, dass es diesen Ort hier
gibt, gut für uns beide.
Randy gehört zur Familie.
Er ist wie ein Bruder für mich
durch all die Jahre,
in denen wir
zusammen gefeiert haben.
Wir kennen uns seit 2002,
das sind 17 Jahre.
Wir verbringen Weihnachten zusammen,
alle Feiertage.
Allen Tessinern in Los Angeles
stehen wir nahe,
sind ihnen verbunden.
* Entspannte Westerngitarrenklänge *
Ein kleines Paradies.
Ein Vorzeigepaar ohne Kinder.
Kinder - das stand für uns zwei
nicht in den Sternen.
Damit mussten wir uns eben abfinden.
Und jetzt ist es so:
Wir zwei sind es.
Aber wir haben unseren Neffen
und die beiden Nichten.
Für uns sind sie
fast wie eigene Kinder.
Jetzt verwöhnen wir sie eben.
- Nach Strich und Faden.
Das ist nicht schlecht für sie.
Ja, nun ist es eben so.
So ist das Leben.
Man kann es nicht kontrollieren.
Man muss das Leben akzeptieren -
und das Beste daraus machen.
Dadurch fühlen wir uns auch freier,
können hin- und herziehen,
wie es uns gefällt.
Weil wir nur zu zweit sind,
können wir tun und lassen,
was wir wollen.
Das ist mir wichtig.
Auch nach 33 Jahren
sitzen wir noch immer zusammen hier.
Obwohl ein grosser Abstand
zwischen uns liegt.
Das ist
die sog. safety zone.
* Schnattern *
Für Lauriane steht bereits
das Semesterende vor der Tür.
Die letzten Monate
sind viel zu schnell vergangen.
Ich fühle mich hier
ein bisschen wie in den Ferien,
aber ich muss ja lernen.
Ich hätte Lust, nach Mexiko
zu fahren. Mir reicht's langsam!
Man hatte mir die Unis
in den Staaten empfohlen,
weil es leicht sei,
gute Noten zu bekommen.
Alle ruhten sich
und machten Stadtausflüge.
So ist es aber nicht,
zumindest nicht in L.A.
Ich habe viel weniger Freizeit,
als ich dachte.
Ich schlafe nicht viel
und nach langen Tagen
lerne ich noch in der Bibliothek -
nicht wirklich lustig.
Man merkt, dass sie hier
doch sehr besorgt sind
um das Wohl der Studierenden.
Gestern gab es
Massagen zum Entspannen.
Sie tun ihr Bestes,
damit alles möglichst gut abläuft.
Die Dining Halls sind cool, weil du
mit verschiedenen Gruppen isst
und dich immer zu irgendjemandem
hinsetzen kannst, ausser heute.
Alle haben Prüfungen.
Ich habe mein Handy vergessen.
Ich langweile mich.
Ich hätte gern
das Vegi-Menü - ohne Bohnen.
Es gibt vier Mensen,
jede hat ein andere Ausrichtung.
Die hier macht
einfache amerikanische Gerichte:
Pizza, Burger, zwei, drei Sachen.
Dann gibt es eine
mit asiatischer Küche.
Eine macht auf gesundes Essen und
eine bietet europäische Gerichte an.
Sie sind hier wirklich recht gut
verglichen mit anderen Dining Halls.
Stimmt, es ist recht teuer,
aber es hat sich für mich gelohnt.
Unterm Strich
bin ich angenehm überrascht.
Ich befürchtete, auf typisch
amerikanische Klischees zu treffen.
Aber ich finde die Leute hier
alle sehr nett.
Vielleicht liegt es auch daran,
dass wir in Kalifornien sind.
Man hatte mir gesagt, Kalifornien
sei der beste Bundesstaat.
In der ersten Woche
hatte ich noch befürchtet,
dass die Leute
zu oberflächlich seien.
Aber ich habe
überhaupt keine Probleme.
Kommt noch hinzu,
dass ich richtig Glück hatte
mit meinen Zimmerkolleginnen,
die sind echt nett.
Alles in allem bin ich sehr zu-
frieden mit meinem Aufenthalt hier.
* Entspannte Westerngitarrenklänge *
Das Abenteuer Hollywood,
der American Football ...
Ich könnte
so viele Geschichten erzählen.
Im tiefsten Innern
habe ich mir immer gesagt,
dass ich es bereut hätte,
wenn ich nicht weggegangen wäre.
* Gemächliche Rockmusik *
Es ist gut,
dass wir beide Künstler sind.
So können wir uns gegenseitig un-
terstützen, und sie hilft mir sehr.
Ich mache Musik für sie
und zeige ihr Bilder,
und sie macht dasselbe für mich.
Sie zeigt mir ihre Bilder.
Es ist gut,
diese Unterstützung zu haben,
sich gut zu kennen und zu sehen,
wie sich ihre Arbeit
auch weiterentwickelt.
Sie arbeitet immer.
Es tut gut, diese Energie
ständig um sich zu haben.
Das bin ich,
kurz bevor ich Genf verlassen habe.
Das bist du?
- Ja.
Erkennst du mich nicht?
Hier: ja.
Da sehe ich ein bisschen aus wie du.
Mit langen Haaren habe ich
meine Mutter noch nie gesehen.
Das bin ich, okay?
Jetzt sehe ich es.
Die Hausbesetzungen
waren immer auch eine Party.
Schau mal!
Da hatte ich schon längere Haare.
Und hier bin ich in meinem Atelier
am Malen, und hier bin ich im Cafe.
Hier habe ich sie sofort erkannt.
Das ist das Genfer Ilot 13,
wo ich eine Zeit lang gelebt habe.
Dann war ich ziemlich frustriert,
denn auf einmal
gab es eine Hierarchie.
Und Leute mit weniger Charisma, die
aber vielleicht verrückter waren,
oder die, die Sachen weniger
politisch sahen und kreativer waren.
Auf die wurde weniger gehört.
- Und du?
Ich gehörte
nicht zu den Wortführern.
Es ist super cool, zu sehen,
dass meine Mutter so unabhängig
und frei war, als sie jung war.
Sie folgte ihrer Leidenschaft.
Ich finde das total bewundernswert.
Ich habe das Studium immer
als Möglichkeit zum Reisen gesehen.
Deshalb war ich zuerst
an der Rijksakademie in Amsterdam
und dann an der UCLA in Los Angeles,
um einen Master of Fine Arts
zu machen.
Poitepoite.
Wir verlieren Freunde,
wir finden neue Freunde.
Das ist die Reise des Lebens,
das ist super so.
Ich hoffe ja, dass uns
alle Freunde erhalten bleiben,
wenigstens ein bisschen -
und sei es nur im Herzen.
Aus den Augen,
aber nicht aus dem Sinn.
Dora und Pasqual verabschieden sich
von ihren Freunden.
Wir schätzen eure
jahrelange Freundschaft sehr.
Und du schuldest mir noch 20 $.
Ihr alle werdet uns fehlen,
aber, haha,
wir werden in der Schweiz sein,
haha,
während ihr alle
Donald J. Trump habt.
(Alle) Stop!
Abschiedsessen für Dora und Pasqual -
nur das Heimweh ist nicht eingeladen.
Es ist ein wenig traurig,
aber auch ein bisschen gut.
Ich bin froh, dass wir
in die Schweiz zurückkehren.
Alles hat ein Anfang und ein Ende.
Leute, seid bitte ruhig
für einen Moment!
Das sind die Leute,
die in unserem Haus wohnen werden.
Ein Toast auf Dora.
Sie werden uns sehr fehlen,
Pasqual und Dora.
Ich hatte das Glück,
Dora kennengelernt zu haben,
als ich ganz unten war.
Ich hatte den Job gewechselt,
mein Leben war ein einziges Chaos.
Doras Energie,
ihr Charisma und alles an ihr
haben mich sehr beeindruckt.
Ihre Tanzstunden
besuchte ich wegen ihr.
Sie bringt alle zusammen,
das ist der Sinn des Tanzens.
Wenn die Ballettstunde vorbei war,
wissen Sie, was sie zu uns sagte?
"Raus, raus jetzt, raus mit euch!"
Wenn ich als Tanzlehrerin
so etwas höre,
dann erkenne ich plötzlich,
wie viel Verantwortung Lehrer haben.
Es kommt nicht darauf an,
was man unterrichtet.
Man muss den Leuten wirklich
eine Lebenshaltung beibringen.
"Wen in L.A. die Liebe berührt,
dem auch der Erfolg gebührt."
(Alle) # Happy birthday to you.
Der Mond scheint,
die Seelen zu besänftigen
und die Hektik zu mildern.
Jeder verfolgt seinen Traum.
Jeder lebt sein Leben.
Alles eine Frage der Haltung.
* Entspannte Westerngitarrenklänge *